round down the other end
Grant Williams steps into a three
oh and smart and he's shaking up oh
smart holding his right leg and
screaming in pain
[Applause]
for someone to come you can hear him
on a hush is caught over this crowd as
Mark is smart
in some real pain we'll have a timeout
[Applause]
well here's the play Marcus Smart going
up for the River Watch the right ankle
I mean completely rolls over and then
Lowry
falls down on it and you can see smart
screaming in pain and grabbing that
ankle right away
it's just you stick to your stomach when
you see that and you hear him
this is him walking off putting a little
bit of pressure on it
and now Jimmy Butler gone for the game
for Miami smart he might not play
for the rest of the series this crowd's
gonna go crazy they're showing it up on
the big screen here Marcus Smart's gonna
return
shades of Paul Pierce I don't know if
smart was in a wheelchair
he's still limping though you could see
that well as you can see him walking to
the scorers table right now Marcus Smart
did officially sustain a right angle
spray
keeping him from the floor and Mike that
you can hear
he is loved here in Boston the longest
tenured Celtic